[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce dernier
paris saclay tv avant la rentrée car oui
ce sont les vacances
enfin pas pour tout le monde car c'est
ici à l'edf lab que s'est tenue il ya
quelques jours le paris saclay connexion
un événement qui accueillait lui même un
autre événement paris saclay une veste
c'était une première et c'était une
réussite nous y étions quand on est
doctorant pas évident de devenir
entrepreneur l'université paris saclay
relève le défi avec dr preneur rial une
formation intense en quatre jours
seulement et des résultats très positifs
vous entendrez les témoignages à suivre
aussi notre focus sur versailles satory
ouest un projet d'aménagement concerté
et discuter une réunion publique de
synthèse a permis de faire le poids
ensuite on vous mettra en appétit avec
un tout nouveau lieu de restauration
son petit nom eyrieux à une restaurant
inter entreprises administrations à
paris saclay il a été inauguré à
palaiseau nous avons rencontré
l'architecte
enfin notre agenda ce sera la fin de
cette émission
c'est donc ici à edf l'ap que c'est nul
paris saclay connexion un rendez vous de
l'innovation ouvert aux acteurs du
public et du privé et qui a accueilli
pour la première fois paris saclay
invest un événement dans l'événement
dont est une réussite je vous le disais
va start up ou plus présente et défendre
leurs projets tout de suite les
explications de philippe van damne mal
le président directeur général de le pps
[Musique]
la première fois maintenant combine
l'événement traditionnel de le pea qui
s'appelle paris saclay invest avec
l'événement qui avait porté même
dernière la communauté d'agglomération
donc c'est ça permet de donner une
dynamique complémentaire à sa ce projet
avec effectivement une très grande
participation des partenaires sur le
projet c'était une belle dynamique on a
pu constater aujourd'hui vous qu'on
s'est réparti déroule avec la libération
mais le prêt à porter paris saclay
invest notamment avec tous les
partenaires qu'on a des lieux
d'innovation identifier les 140 et 140
candidats au pitch contesté au showroom
faire l'analyse a été jury pour conduire
à cet événement avec 20 20 start up qui
ont fait un pitch pour chercher des
partenaires financiers ou industriels et
et les expositions de démonstrateurs
avec le showroom donc c'était tout cette
participation en forte avec en parallèle
toujours dans pareil paris saclay invest
c'est le nombre de rendez vous à ses
gigantesques qui ont eu lieu entre des
entrepreneurs et puis des partenaires
financiers notamment
c'est traduit vraiment de dynamique on
ressent maintenant de plus en plus c'est
des mecs de paris saclay dynamique que
l'état lancé il ya quelques années qui
prend une dimension internationale avec
cette université de paris saclay qui
était maintenant une une vraie marque
reconnue à l'international et c'est
dynamique de territoire sur le grand
territoire du plateau avec les transats
l'opération que son versailles grand
parc saint quentin en yvelines et les
communes et d'agglomérations de paris
saclay dans l'essonne
cette dynamique globale elle est là ça a
été redit encore une fois et ça va le
faire que croître dans les années qui
viennent et je suis ravi on sent bien
cette dynamique et la participation des
entreprises présentes comme edf qui nous
accueille encore aujourd'hui qui
participent à cette dynamique et qui
veulent aussi faire réussir paris-saclay
position innovation ça c'était au
potager donc paris sacré connexion pour
moi c'est le début de quelque chose
je pense formidable donc je tenais à
remercier date où les tous les
partenaires et aussi de bien évidemment
territoire qui est de riches ressources
et qu'on espère fera procéder dans les
prochaines années
merci à devenir entrepreneur monter sa
start up ça s'apprend même quand on est
doctorant à l'université paris saclay
relève le défi avec dr prône arial une
formation intense quatre jours seulement
mais qui séduit regardez
[Musique]
bienvenue au centre d'entrepreneuriat
s'appelle le 503 son entrepreneuriat de
l'institut d'optique au dock peut prôner
rial alors c'est une formation de
l'université paris saclay qui est
organisé par l'institut d'optique et
c'est la première édition 100% dédié aux
doctorants dans les laboratoires il ya
plein d'idées à valoriser et également
des gens qui se demandent si
potentiellement ils pourraient pas créer
une start up donc l'idée c'est d'amener
ses doctorants à réfléchir lors de cette
session qui dure quatre jours alors
quelques jours ses courses et danse
il ya des tonnes à apprendre beaucoup
d'outils la méthode du design thinking
quelle nouvelle pour eux puisque c'est
une méthode qui est basée sur
potentiellement a besoin d'un client ou
notre besoin d'un utilisateur et de
réfléchir à des solutions
alors ces problèmes potentiels on a
demandé à des entreprises du centre
d'entrepreneuriat de nous ont préparés
quelques-uns des problématiques qui vont
pouvoir amener des solutions simples ou
pas techno plus pas et qui
potentiellement vont intéresser un
client qui sera prêt à acheter acheter
cette solution ça veut dire
potentiellement aussi avoir de quoi
créer une star
ça déroule sur quatre jours
effectivement où on alterne les phases
où un produit méthodo et des outils
qu'ils appliquent immédiatement sur
leurs projets et on les prépare
rapidement puisque demain ils vont avoir
un jury qui va évaluer la pertinence de
leur travail de la semaine que ce soit
en terme d' équipes en termes de réponse
un problème qui a bien été identifié et
également un potentiel de avec un
business model qui pourrait tenir la
route pour konami starter la fin sera
qui a envie et qui veut poursuivre sur
ces sujets là notre projet ça a été en
fait de développer une solution pour les
personnes qui ont des problèmes en fête
visuelle
donc soit les malvoyants les personnes
aveugles elles ont des problèmes en fait
pour l'accès en particulier aux piscines
au niveau de la formation en fait ça
nous a énormément apporté par ce que
l'ensemble de l'équipe est doctorante et
en tant que doctorant en fait on est
toute la journée en train de parler
d'eux
de sciences qui sont extrêmement
précises et on n'a pas ce regard de la
finalité en fait nos recherches où on
est une personne qui va devoir
l'utiliser
c'est la première fois que le fait je
trouve c'est un assez bon à
l'entraînement malgré le temps qui est
relativement court de quatre jours mais
c'est extrêmement intense et en fait on
la meilleure manière d'apprendre c'est
vraiment de le faire et cette formation
le permet donc ça c'est quoi on vous
emmène maintenant à satory ouest 8e
quartier de versailles zone
d'aménagement concerté une réunion
publique de synthèse préalable a permis
de faire un point
nous y étions voici ce qu'il faut en
retenir
[Musique]
[Rires]
on se retrouvait ce soir effectivement
pour une réunion publique de
concertation préalable à la création de
la zac centre et ouest le plateau de
satory donc c'est situé à versailles
et c'est l'un des sites majeurs de
l'opération d'intérêt national
paris-saclay sur sa théorie on a un des
éléments principaux de développement du
projet qui est la gare de
18 qui donc est un élément important la
réunion de public de ce soir elle clôt
une première phase une phase importante
dit donc de concertation préalable donc
c'est à la fois un aboutissement par
rapport à toutes les étapes de
concertation que nous avons mené des
ateliers cartes sur table avec les
associations les entreprises du site
elle s'est déroulée en parallèle des
premières études en particulier l'étude
d'impact de la zac 7h et ouest
et puis c'est aussi un commencement
puisqu'elle va nous permettre d'adopter
dossier de création de zac
en fin d'année on conseil
d'administration de l'établissement pour
passer aux étapes ultérieures et nous
projeter dans l'opérationnel
effectivement à partir de l'année
prochaine avec des opérations majeures
de dépollution de déplacement de ses
fameuses pistes des cèdres à vous parler
ce soir qui sont un élément assez
essentiel de ce territoire de satory
pour les entreprises du site
et puis ça va permettre effectivement de
dérouler l'ensemble des études urbaines
également avant de démarrer les travaux
d'ici environ deux ans
un retour ce soir
disons normale est plutôt constructif
des intervenants sur les préoccupations
qui sont certes habituel d'essentiel
d'accessibilité de gestion des mobilités
dans le cadre de leurs projets
d'aménagement
on est sur un site assez exceptionnel en
plateau boisée avec des sujets de
gestion de l'eau des eaux pluviales en
particulier de covisibilité avec les
sites classés et donc tous ces sujets là
préoccupé assistance ce qui est assez
normal il figure parmi nos
préoccupations aussi traité dans l'étude
d'impact
donc je pense qu'on a un débat
constructif et on va tenter de continuer
d'avoir par la suite
comme promis nous voici devant le hérie
ea le tout nouveau restaurant inter
entreprises administrations paris saclay
qui est situé à palaiseau
il y a tout juste d'être inauguré son
architecte olivier delaitre nous
explique comment il a conçu ce bâti
[Musique]
messieurs on est prêt 1 2 3 on y va
c'est parti
[Musique]
nous avons défini un parti à ses efforts
en fête avec mes collaborateurs et on a
imaginé en fait faire un grand volume
unitaire avec un plafond unique en bois
des parois très absorbante parce que le
confort acoustique est essentiel dans un
restaurant bien évidemment tout c'est un
moment de calme et de tranquillité avec
des matériaux aussi absolument au sol
donc
des matériaux souples et résistantes
donc vous voyez ce volume avec des
contrastes et dans lequel la lumière
entre par tous les espaces nous avons
fait une modifier un certain nombre de
choses créer des mezzanines pour que le
futur restaurant puisse bénéficier
partout des spas s'éclairer avec une vue
vous lui en ambiance à ses causes y donc
avec des matériaux qui valorise des
espaces donc un sol qu'on a décidé assez
sombre des meubles à c'est assez clair
des murs est très clair pour apporter la
lumière est partout vous voyez ces
parois perforé qui sont destinés à
apporter une qualité acoustique qui est
très importante pour le bâtiment
c'est un restaurant de 800 couverts il
ya 500 m² de cuisine il ya mille 6000 m²
de salles à manger
le bâtiment est plus destiné aux
entreprises qui sont déjà sur le site au
cea de saclay qui est donc comme sien
énergie atomique yukiya grands espaces
ici où différentes espaces de recherche
aussi qu'ils seront plus ou moins social
et de la cité donc une clientèle plutôt
là je dirais d'un à d'un âge moyen et
non pas seulement des étudiants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre agenda à présent le climatique
fait étape le 31 juillet sur votre
territoire
paris saclay est l'une des escales
françaises proposer une quarantaine
d'étudiants ses internationaux ils
viennent plancher sur la mise en oeuvre
du réseau au chaud froid
ensuite ils poursuivront leur périple
avec trois autres semaines réparties
dans deux pays différents
où on s'arrête là paris saclay tv prend
des vacances bien méritées on vous
retrouve à la rentrée d'ici là vous
restez informés grâce au site
au ps point fr merci de votre attention
et à très bientôt
[Musique]